so I'm going to talk about the updated
ribosomal RNA databases these are
sequences that you can use for
identification and follow genetic
analysis of fungi bacteria and archaea
as I said a minute ago Barbara Robertson
is here he's a fungal refseq curator and
I'm Peter Cooper and I'm gonna be doing
a presentation although I'm not a
subject matter expert on this so there's
an outline what we're going to talk
about today we'll talk a little bit
about what targeted Llosa are which is a
name that we give to these kinds of
sequences we're going to talk about
today a little brief background on the
structure of ribosomal RNA genes I'll
talk a little bit about the scope and
content of the ncbi refseq problem RNA
gene projects which include the 16s
bacteria archaea the fungal i TS
internal transcribed spacer region which
is the largest one that we also have the
20 a large subunit and a small subunit
database I'll talk about searching and
retrieving the data and we'll do some
live demonstrations okay so we talked
about things at NCBI called targeted
low-side these are things that people
think of as marker genes barcode
sequences and a person that I work with
calls a measuring tape sequences which i
think is very nice using for a
phylogenetic analysis or for taxon
identification and this is a molecular
identification of taxa as opposed to
traditional morphological means where
you're keying something out or looking
at the structure of a morphology of
calling me on a plate or something like
that some examples of these kinds of
sequences are cytochrome oxidase bar
code sequences some protein coding genes
various ones are used the mitochondrial
dilute sequences and the ones we're
going to talk about today which is the
structural RNA genes for prokaryotes
there is at 16s of 23s 5s where
eukaryotes there is an 18s five point
80s and a 28 or 25 s depending upon the
group of organisms and there's a special
kind of sequence that's that's more
variable that's between the five point
eight s and those other two subunits
they're called the internal transcribed
spacer regions i TS 1 and i TS 2 and
there's a
to apply this or energy we make
sequences for these things we call them
reference targeted loci and we have
these records that are available from
refseq also one of the points I want to
make to you today is that there blast
databases that we've already made for
you that you can use the ribosomal RNA
genes from you know sort of microbes in
the traditional sense of that word in
the old-fashioned sense which includes
the prokaryotes UK archaea and bacteria
as well as fungi the real good thing
about these sequences that we produce is
that these are associated for the most
part with taxonomic type material plant
material of course is the material or
specimen or culture that the new species
descriptions are based on and so there's
a this ensures that the correct name is
tied with the sequence which has been a
big problem with sort of sequences going
into GenBank with but the identity may
be incorrect so what are these useful
for these are useful for confirming
organisms organism identifications if
you have an unknown they are good for
assigning a preliminary ID or at least a
placement in taxes on a group you're not
necessarily going to be able to identify
this species and we'll talk a little bit
more about that and you can use these to
construct phylogenetic trees or to put
them in your phylogenetic trees to get
some anchor points and things like that
okay so let's look a little bit at the
structure of the RNA ribosomal RNA genes
in prokaryotes and eukaryotes talk about
where these sequences are with with
reference to those two things so here is
an example this is using our graphical
sequence viewer to look at the privates
mRNA cassette there are multiple of
these and a lot of bacteria this in fact
this is e.coli there are seven copies of
this in the e coli genome there is a 16s
gene that's shown on the left-hand side
of this slide here and that's the one
that we have a corresponding record that
were going to be talking about today so
this is the refseq RNA for this 16s and
this is just showing you a blast
alignment to that part of the e coli
genome here's the 23 s and the 5s
ribosomal RNA genes there these are the
main reagents were going to be talking
about the day for bacteria
and then these are the circular RNA
genes for a fungus this is a yeast
kazakhstani africana
and you can see the structure of the RNA
cassette there this is the 5s RNA the
18s RNA the 5.8 s RNA and there's a 25 s
the large subunit RNA so this guy right
here the fly point is there's a space
between the 18s and a space between 25 s
this is the internal transcribed spacer
regions there are two of them one on
each side these are more variable than
that conserved party genes themselves
and we make a sequence this is a
internal transcribed spacer reason
refseq that includes that
five-point-eight but it also includes
some of the flanked on either side so it
includes that i TS one and the i TS to
sequence so that's a very useful kind of
sequence to use for identification and
followed genetic analysis ok so a little
bit more about these targeted low-side
data sets that we have one way to access
them is through their bio projects site
there are a number of these i've
highlighted the ones we're going to talk
about today the 16s for my bacteria and
archaea the fungi the internal
transcribed spacer region the IPS the 28
s and the 18s and those are the bio
project IDs these are all part of these
targeted low side projects that we have
at NCBI
what's good about these bio project
identifiers is they're very useful for
retrieving these sequences he set the
sequences from the entre system and I'll
show you that in a little bit so looking
at what kind of organisms or what kind
of tax amount of distribution we have
for the organisms and the groups from
the 16s this is a breakdown of what
groups are represented and what I've
done here is I've used sort of a name
that's sort of a handle for a group of
bacteria these are the so called blast
names that we have in our taxonomy
database and so these are groups that
most people recognize the highest most
represent a group or the high GC
gram-positive bacteria and then there
was a number of other organisms
represented here we have a broad
spectrum of
things of course we'll talk later on
this is just a just a tiny bit of the
microbial diversity that's out there
there are 20 1333 these records 20,000
of them for bacteria 979 for archaea and
it's about 16,000 species at this point
the fungal database is smaller
there are eleven thousand seven hundred
fifty one records eleven thousand six
hundred and sixty-five species are
represented and again this is a
breakdown of the IPS fungal here they're
also the 28s and the 18s there are
slightly smaller databases this is again
breakdown by blast names so these are
not necessarily names that fungal
taxonomy
would like to do you use I Barbara
didn't like them very much actually but
they're good handles for groups of fungi
this is a little bit better breakdown of
the taxonomic coverage basically by
showing you the number of records at
various levels kingdom phylum class
order family genus and species for the
small subunit the ITSM the large subunit
and Barbara made this slide it's very
nice and it shows you that the number in
the various groups of ascomycete there's
the largest group that has eight
thousand four hundred two records and
then so on down species level also in
terms of phylogenetic analysis a lot of
times people want to use combinations of
genes the table at the bottom of this
slide shows you what we have for
particular attacks on so for example the
last line is are the ones that we have
everything for where we have the small
subunit the IPS will large subunit and
so that's um 1402 taxon that had that
and it she has for the those that had
the most factor represented in these
classes and this is a breakdown like
phylum class order family and genus here
and these are useful if you want to use
you know both or as many of the genes
and apologetic tree so you can get those
from or FTP signer from the refseq FTP
site I'll straighten that in just a
minute so if you want to look at the one
of these records that this is a flat
file of one of these records just to
show you the kind of information that's
on here and you can see these in our on
train system first of all the definition
line is controlled by the refseq
curators and that means that the
organism information in this depth line
is going to be updated with the correct
organism what happens a lot of times
with the GenBank records is that the
definition line organism will be out of
date even though the taxonomy is updated
in the organism field and the important
thing about the DEF line we talked about
the blast databases or the definition
line is that that's the thing that shows
up in the blast descriptions and a lot
of people are looking at the species
name from there so that's why it's
useful to use these refseq records
because we're going to ensure that that
species name is the best one we come up
with here's a link to the refseq bio
project there's a link to the original
GenBank or insdc submitted record that
was used to make this record and what's
very nice here is that you can go back
you can go to our bio collections to
look at the type at the culture
collection here and you can link to the
outside culture collection directly and
see about how will you order this
particular culture to verify this
yourself if you wanted to or did you
work on this yourself this is the 16s
record this is for lactobacillus Tobruk
II I and of course it has this refseq
accession number here and here is an the
corresponding kind of record for one of
the IPS sequences for a fungus this is
strike a fight on rubrum and again you
have the curated deaf-blind
the link to the bio project and a link
to the outside culture collection where
you could order this particular culture
if you wanted to verify or do work on
this yourself okay so let's talk a
little bit about how you can get access
to these data
get them directly from our on turing
nucleotide system and it's quite easy to
download these because they're not huge
sets of sequences you can use these
queries right here the bio project
number followed by the square bracket
filled in the nucleotide system to get
the sets directly and then you can just
use the send to menu on the upper right
hand side to download these if you want
the sets in a handy file that you can
download you can go directly to our
refseq ftp site and the URL is given
here and there's a targeted lo site
directory that has access to the archaea
the bacteria and the fungal sequences
the other thing i want to mention and
actually the title in this webinar
because one of the things that you want
to kind of promote is that you can get
these as blast databases and we're going
to see in a few minutes that they're
also available on the web of course and
that's we're going to be using for our
examples there right there on the ftp
site and the blast ftp site in the DB
directory you can get the ones we're
going to talk about today the 16s 18s
20s and the IPS these are the refseq
databases I will point out and you'll
see the way if you go there that there
are sequences that we have gleaned from
GenBank for these particular regions
from other organisms I'm not going to
talk about those databases today but
you're welcome to check them out one of
the really cool things about the plastic
bases now is we have these version 5
blast databases so that the taxonomy
information is is baked into them and so
you can use some switches on the plasti
B command program to dump out various
things from the database what organisms
are in there what the accession numbers
are and all those kinds of things so
that's very handy the other thing that's
nice about getting a blast database is
even if you don't run blast against them
directly is that you can use them as a
way of dumping out the sequences in
various formats and this is a really
nice way to get the fast day that you
could use other applications one of the
things that I should point out is that
the blast databases are non redundant so
maybe cases where the sequence for
different species is the same they're
going to be collapsed into a single fast
day although you will still be able to
see the two titles in the blast database
so if you really want to have every fast
day sequence you want to use the refseq
download if you want all the records
instead of the non-redundant set that's
part of blast so let me just point out a
few things that are important to realize
when you're using these kinds of a
targeted leucite to do certain things
one of the important ones and I sort of
alluded to this earlier is it this is
limited coverage and acts are not a
clear presentation so if you just do a
quick count of the species level nodes
at NCBI for bacteria and fungi and again
these are often things that don't have
formal names or just things that are at
the end of the taxonomy classification
there's four hundred fifty thousand
bacteria 150 thousand fungi from
bacteria we have only sixteen thousand
sequences or species in that 16s
database for fungi there's only twelve
thousand in the IPS database ha you know
who knows how many species of microbes
there are on the planet I have seen
estimates upwards of ten to the 30th
species so this is just the tip of the
iceberg in terms of microbial diversity
and so if you have an unknown sequence
there may not be the corresponding
species in these database also just
using 16s and IPS alone there may be you
know a lot more sequence a lot more
species out there because there's going
to be some species that are not
separable based on the IPS or the 16s
alone and you need to use a multi
analysis to get accurate identification
have to get accurate phylogenetic trees
now the technique that we're going to be
talking about today that searches these
is the quartz blast and if you go to the
blast page now you have a separate radio
button that I should have highlighted
here for you that you can click and you
have access to these 16s 18s 20s and the
IPS databases from the pulldown list you
can also restrict only those from type
material and most of these are
from type material so that's all very
good one thing to keep in mind we'll see
some good examples of this in a few
minutes is that there are some
limitations that blast has one is that
Blast sorts by the e-value in alignment
score and not by the percent identity
and this causes some things to happen
that that may be confusing at first and
that's that you're a lot longer sequence
that it's a worse match may appear
higher in the results so you need to
take a look at both query coverage and
percent identity to help identify things
also blast doesn't use position specific
information in the alignment so every
position in the alignment gets equal
weight but in reality certain positions
are more informative than others so you
need to look at how the match fits into
a tree bowl from the results for example
to get a better idea of how the
placement of the sequence is you also
may need to build trees using real
multiple sequence alignments in tree
building using multiple genes to get an
accurate view of things okay so let's do
some live examples and so I'm going to
switch over to a web browser and this is
where would be useful if you wanted to
follow along to try to get the the text
record the text document that's on the
FTP sites let me get out of this this is
one other one so if you go to the site
you can see this is sort of run through
that we're going to do for the demo ISM
the first thing I want to do is just do
a simple blast search and a search to
find a particular targeted locusts
sequence so what I'm gonna do is use
that one of those queries that I talked
about where you're searching for the bio
project I'm going to add an organism
search to this this is a and our key on
that we have 16s sequence four so I'm
going to go over here to the nucleotide
database
you
and notice that we have two different
16s ribosomal RNA sequences and that's
because there are these are divergence
from each other so we make two different
sequences and what I'm going to do is
this is an unusual kind of situation
this is an organism that has two central
repla cons and we can actually find
these for this cassette in the genome so
let's do that as an example just to show
you how these things line up and take a
look at a an RNA operon and one of these
organisms so let me go click over here
to run blast what that's going to do is
to put this in to put my two sequences
into the blast form here I notice that
we could search against CR and IITs
databases but we're not going to do that
right now what we're going to do is to
go ahead and search against the genomes
so I'm going to search against the
representative genomes which are a
special set of genomes at NCBI and this
happens to be one of the ones that's in
there and I'll go ahead and type the
species name in there to sort of limit
our search so I want her hallo arkla
Maris more to I which is the organism we
searched with or and go ahead and run
that now if you want to retrieve the
results you didn't run the search
yourself you can do that pretty easily
from the URL that I've given you here so
I've saved these blast results so if you
just copy and paste that URL into your
web browser you should be able to just
retrieve them I've got mine back here
and so notice that we have a hit on the
two different chromosomes there's a set
of results for the first sequence the
first sequence matches is chromosome 1
perfectly the sec the first sequence
matches chromosome 2 less perfectly 94.9
2 percent identity you can just see if
you switch over to the other sequence
here
that we now swap them okay so this is
matching the other is set and if we want
to look at this you can jump down to the
alignment here let's take a look at the
graphics view which is a nice way of
looking at your results here and there
are the two sequences that we search
with and if we zoom out a little bit we
can see that now this is just on the
opposite strand here but there is the
60s the 23 s and 5s and here is our
perfect match to this particular portion
of chromosome 1 so this is a case where
we made two different
sequences because of the divergent 16's
regions on these particular organism
okay and let's do another exercise and
with 16s and what I have here if you
wanted to follow along there are three
different sequences from
solo species that don't have a species
identification on them so what we can do
is to try to find the best species match
for these against the 16s database so
I'm gonna copy those I can go back here
and edit my search to get to the blast
page if I want to and I can reset the
page just to start over again
and so this is our first look at the RNA
our ITF databases ribosomal RNA IPF's
databases here I'll select a radio
button and the top one the first one is
the one we want that 16s ribosomal RNA
sequences I won't change any other
parameters I can leave this I took
insect check for sequences from type
material just to make sure that I'm
looking at the type it strains here and
run blast and so these there are three
sets of results here now the three
different ones that we sort with and
let's take a look at this so we have
some potential matches here one of the
things I want you to notice and this is
the point that I made earlier there are
differences in the lengths of these
sequences that we have made and so what
happens is the best match which is in
this particular case is bacillus
thuringiensis
is lower down in my match so what I want
to do a lot of times to make sure that
I'm getting the best percent identity is
to go ahead and sort by person identity
and then I can see that my best match is
bacillus thuringiensis
and that might be and then there's
another one here for a different strain
of bacillus thuringiensis another thing
you can always do with these to sort of
verify things is to look at the distance
to your result so we'll do that more
than once today just to see how it fits
into the tree
ban this note here and you can see oh
man to see what's going on with that and
so there it is fitting right it between
those two bacillus thuringiensis
sequences so now do I know that that's
the species that it is I don't know for
sure
that's very I've got it certainly within
its close to that particular species and
I won't go through the other ones it's
pretty much exactly the same exercise
and the reason this is happening is
because this NR here this sequence here
is shorter than the other ones and
that's why we get a lower query coverage
here even though the percent identity is
higher so that's why those matches might
be drop down a little bit in your blast
results okay so let's go on and move on
a little bit so let's move over to a
fungal clone here I'm going to retrieve
it just so you can see what it is I'll
go ahead and retrieve it is from a
nucleotide database and so this is from
up what we call pop site at NCBI whereas
people have submitted a whole bunch of
sequences in this particular case it
says it's an uncultured troll fungus and
there's a clone and we don't really know
what it is they have identified that it
contains the 18s part of the internal
the internal transcribed spatially
reason one and so on and so forth so we
can run a search with this and again we
can do the same thing we did before by
running black
and again we're going to pick one of our
RNA IPS database with this time let's
pick the I TS
so this is a fungal sequence we'll go
ahead and do a blast search with that
you
and so again we have to make sure that
we're looking at the best matches here
so we want to make sure that we sort by
percent I did any
and if I do that that my best match
turns out to be the pasilla Denis ileum
sub reef essence here now is this the
species that we were sure that it is we
can't be sure but this is the best match
and if we can again we can take a look
at the tree if we want you to see where
that fits into the tree see if that sort
of confirms what we're thinking about
that
Zeon and it stopped
closest thing it's in this group of
organisms here so those ones that I
showed you work pretty well and now
wanna the last thing I want to do is a
fairly complicated one involves a number
of different steps but it want to point
out to you on the last one basically
that there are some things you need to
think about the database and the length
of the query sequence and all those
things matter in terms of the ID that
you might particularly get you might get
so I'm gonna go back ok smoke over here
so this is a fungal sequence that
Barbara provided to me and let's start
out by doing a search against a
different database when we haven't done
a search against yet which is the
default nucleotide database
so I'll change my data
standard nucleotide databases here and
I'll leave my limit
to type material on let's go ahead and
run that
you
once just for the moment let's just look
at our best
matches here we have this ordinary
species there's a bunch of Corden areas
here
cordon area cesky is the one that looks
like it's the best match let's take a
look at that match for a second I just
want to point out something to you so if
we take a look at the graphics link
it'll give us some information about
what this match looks like but the other
thing that points out is that the
sequence that we're dealing with our
query sequence incorporates more than
just the IPS regions here so here's a 28
s and so this thing has a big chunk of
the 28 s in it that's an important thing
to keep in mind so for example we could
think about doing a search against 28 s
but they're more conserved in the
regions down here that we're interested
in and so you can see that basically
right here by looking at where the
mismatches are so we've got mismatches
in the IPS regions nothing with really
within the five-pointed s and nothing
really within the 28 s but it does tell
me that my sequence is longer than just
the IPS region let's go back and run
this against the IPS type strange
database and see what that comes out
like so
yes here
and we'll run this search
so we now have a different species at
the top this is Corden arias Vinicius I
notice that you can see that the query
coverage is 71% you know points out
something that we pointed out before
that our query sequence is longer than
this idea sequence that were matching
and quickly notice according areas cesky
which we had before is now number three
now let's do the thing we did before
we'll take a look at the distance to
your results and see what comes up when
that happens
you
expand that and zoom to look at it so
now when we look at the distance through
your results the closest species is this
one ordinarius senemo meais and if you
look up here you can find the other ones
in the tree there are different parts of
the tree the ones that we had matches it
before so we now have a different
closest match let's do one more thing
the thing that we've been doing all
along which is a sort by person identity
and now we have ordinary as Croesus as
our best match so that's the one that
gives us the best percent identity so we
have four different we've identified
four different closest matches like
ordinary of species cesky Vinicius
cinema meais and Croesus which one is it
that's a good question and so in order
to figure that out you may find that you
can't figure it out and in fact there's
a slide that Barber provided for me that
shows you what the phylogenetic analysis
was like when they did these species
that we've looked at just now and I'm
gonna switch back to the slides for a
minute to show you the results of that
so these are the feet and species that
we've looked at the Croesus in ammonius
anthony shiest so they're all in here
they're closely related to each other
and it shows you where these things are
and they're different things that we
looked at all we can say is that it
belongs to this species group probably
what we can't give you as a clear
species identification for this and
that's just sort of a cautionary tale of
the kinds of things that you're going to
run into with using glass as a tool and
detective we have a limited tax amount
of coverage for these organisms okay so
we have about ten minutes or so for
questions on well put this slide shows
you where you can get some more
information these are basically our
resources for learning about things if
you have any questions you can write to
the help desk at that info address and
Arana
let's open the floor to see if there's
any questions that we can answer sure
there are a whole bunch of questions so
the first thing we like to talk that
initially are the databases they're
targeted low-side database there's a
number of questions about what types of
sequences are actually located in that
particular database one of the questions
was about what kind of sequences are
there one of the people on the webinar
was mentioning how there may need to be
sadly but have
models of qualities and sequences and is
what is exactly goes into these targeted
lossless I databases what's the level of
curation is it possible to maybe expand
these databases but then fragment them
by those that have really good curation
versus those that may be part of
uncultured taxa or metagenomic profiling
what goes into these targeted lists I
databases so that sounds like a question
that I think Barbara would be best at
answering forever would you like to talk
about that yes I can say a little bit
about this so for the IDS basic database
first of all we do a lot of sequence
quality control looking at Normandy G
characters so that there's not too many
of those we allow only like 0.5%
characters to begin our dataset per
sequence and we look at the assembly
making sure that you know the sequence
is correctly assembled we use the ideas
X program to make sure you know that
everything is present you know with the
complete - today's region is present we
also use that script to check how
complete our sequences are we so some of
our sequences will have a flank on the
small subunit side and a flank on the
North subunit side but it will never be
longer than a hundred races so about I
would say 50% of our data set has
actually complete ideas won't like these
two sequences and those way they are
partial we have a general right that I
statistics we look for genus you know
what is the expected length for that is
one what is the expected length for the
idea - and if we are working with
recover 80% of either we allow it to go
in otherwise if we're too strict in just
you know housing clear to the complete I
just wanted to sequence this thing will
have very few copies of fungal Kingdom
let's see what else yeah we look at make
sure that there's no bookkeeping errors
you know we check the sequence name
Association and and we take you know
that sequences do not sits in weird
places in the phylogenetic tree that
doesn't make sense in terms of its
classification in the incident might
exogamy and I'll just stop here and
Barbara I would say that the same sorts
of you know you would talk specifically
about the formal sequences but the the
the bacterial sequences are also curated
in a smaller way and then the second
part of the question was about making
datasets available for the uncultured
you know extracting those I don't know
that we have any plans to do that and
there are certainly other places where
you can get access to those sequences
yes we don't have any plans to do that
but people can go to the unite and
device and do that sequence quality
control they generate clusters of it and
you know try to put species of offices
names on it okay thanks rotted close to
time but maybe you can pick out maybe
one more question that would be probably
okay actually very popular but let's
again go into the sequences and you're
looking for guidance on particularly
fungal identification but also and maybe
you can extend this to bacterial
identification as well is IDs for fungal
identification specific enough or there
are other genes that might be good to
include or would enhance the ability to
identify fungals sequences particularly
to the species level on top of that and
then is it possible to have more than
just one let's just say i TS and maybe
another gene in order to do the the
identification and then most
regeneration yes
so there's some secondary power cuts
that's probably important especially
when it comes to Trichoderma and
Kazarian and one of those protein coding
barcodes is called the elongation factor
one and that can be used here in terms
of other tools three placement tools is
probably the best tool to use I know is
a group called team as they maintain a
reference tree and you can use your
ideas or your elongation factor sequence
and you can search against the tree and
it will placement of your sequence will
be shown you know I like it fashioned in
their tree to show you know exists
okay whose area misses like I could area
or whatever I think they only did Pazuzu
Mike Athena this fungi other tools yeah
we would just be the clustering tools
but I would steer away from that don't
rather do like a tree placement to other
about coding sequences that one can use
things ought to be what I ought to be
too but I think elongation factor one is
probably the best go to protein coding
gene after IPS it depends on you know
the plate
or the genius you're working with I
suggest doing some homework and you know
if you're working on a specific genius
can see what the literature say in
addition time is which is they breakable
our gene to use we are essentially out
of time so what I think I'd like to do
is go ahead and in the webinar and
thanks Ron Barbara for participating in
this thanks everybody